because he begins to learn to drive the
first thing the right thing
I prefer to buy a calculated one than to
buy food for the house
in other countries there were illegal barriers
in cuba and the world thinks of a
porsche lamborghini
gdr here a car from the year 30 is run and
baba is one of  the most recognized
in illegal races the logo of his son
follows in his footsteps and carries it
in his blood
in the year 62 the
claw races in Cuba were stopped thanks to the bone
what is more or less we have been doing
competitive activity  everyone seeing
permission to the government to the police
talk about the rule in cuba and not to
mention pretty they know nothing about
these rules
and there are more than 16 years forcing us
unfortunately from 2006
a strong blow that gave me
life cancer
in total they relieved  the races by
grandmother I lived the race and I felt good
if as long as they take
away the Doria and Ciro side it is a method
I am a medical student but I
like cars I have two p  Assions are
treated from the water doctors tell me and
also as a re-race and follow the
tradition that encompasses
here we have
my car let's go 15 I was making
modifications to it you have to franzén 21 to the
things that I say yes to learn to
run you have to learn  to fix the car
I always imagined that we would go from
mechanical engineering to medicine because I
would like to be a doctor in the future of
priests
the two things are related because
medicine has to avoid and fix
as we see it does with the modes and you think
that the thumb  yellow will have time
of things always on time